all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly thanks YouTube channel
I am checking my thumbnail checking my
audio let me know in the chat
is this working because as you know I am
trash
absolute trash when it comes to freaking
technique technical stuff
um okay I need to switch the thumbnail
on this live
okay okay
here we go change
downloads I'm gonna make it my normal
one
yeah save that okay
hello um so I wasn't gonna stream today
I wasn't I was like I should take the
foot off the gas pedal I should take the
foot off the gas pedal
but I feel bad I missed a show last
night I missed a show last night look it
look it
you know I I like to talk to my people
you know what I mean I really enjoy
speaking with my people
thank you
know because all of you
let me make sure I'm live let me let me
just double check that I'm live because
what I don't want to be doing
what the I thought I switched the
thumbnail all right let's let me double
check this
yeah it says it's switched so maybe it
just hasn't updated yet all right
as my YouTube people can you hear me
okay can you everything good all right
as my um as a YouTuber right
what keeps me going
what child what what
I really should have
you go out last I think you're okay
you better not poop under my floor
during this stream I think you're okay
I think you're okay okay what keeps me
going during these streams is just
knowing that we have such a great
Community here at just pearly things
such a great group of people what
okay wait hold on I mean also guys I am
gonna do events okay I think you're okay
over there
during these streams it's just knowing
that we
oh wait we gotta stop this okay all
right so today I decided I want to react
to some Modern women I want to react to
some beautiful majestic creatures I just
feel like lately I've been too nice
I have been taking my foot off the uh
you know
and I just want to rant I just want to
rant on the internet about whatever
comes to mind but back to the community
okay guys
here put your put your email I'm so
tired of y'all watching me and not
putting in your email emails in the chat
okay we
are gonna do meetups and I know I've
been gaslighting you guys with meetups
for a while okay Pearl's a busy gal
all right you know pearls only got so
much time
laughs
but it's coming okay and it's probably
not gonna be a super in advanced thing
it's not going to be super well planned
I'm literally just gonna text the email
list and say yo tonight we're in this
city or this week we're in this city and
if you want to come come okay
Ellie
I Need You to Breathe less loud
okay fine you want to come on the stream
we're gonna let Ellie come on the stream
okay come here come here dog
we're gonna let you in
come here come here you want to sit
all right
before we're gonna let Ellie in on the
Stream
oh
okay
all right okay
all right if you lick me too much if you
lick me too much you're gonna get pets
you're gonna get pets but if you lick me
too much I'm gonna get annoyed
all right can you breathe less loud it's
like
I do love this dog I do I do
it's a very cute dog very cute okay so
today if you want to react to some
[__] with me [__]
all right
oh
okay I gave you the chair and now you're
abusing this you're abusing this sit sit
sit sit okay can you pretend you sit for
the
okay also if anyone knows of some
ointment I could put on my dog's nose
it's getting kind of bad it's getting
kind of crusty
so
I want to know what in the chat do you
guys want me to react to what have I
been missing out on because
in all honesty
yeah I need to okay
let's do some reactions
there's a bitter you know I haven't
reacted to fresh and fit in a minute
okay
dog can you
okay breathe less loud
all right we're gonna play it
our 34 year old guy is not the same as a
34 year old woman and the reason why is
because the things that make a woman
attractive are you using fertility and
Chastity the things that make a man
attractive are success ambition
confidence like you mentioned earlier
right
um status all these things take time to
acquire so a guy that's 34 versus a girl
that's 34 not the same woman has lost
her body by the time she started four no
offense versus the man if he does the
worst guy he's going up
so it's not the same
that is biological fact
universities
yo here's the thing this is a fact thank
you for joining my memberships Fallon
Fallon welcome to the gang welcome to
the game guys sign up for the forms sign
put your email in the form okay we're
dropping whale merch soon we're doing
some meetups welcome to the gang Fallon
between 18 to 60 they were
what do you find the most attractive
women between 18 to 24.
every guy that I've ever talked to since
my baby daddy has always been younger
than me okay okay but that's amazing
strategy lady this isn't something to
brag about that
that means you can't get the men your
age that means you can't get them on
your age you can only get them younger
men that's not we shouldn't be bragging
about that see women we don't know we
tell on ourselves
but I'm letting you guys in on some
Secrets women
guy that I've talked to after my baby
daddy has been younger than me okay most
of the guys I'm not gonna lie it's
because
because no dude that things
it's another thing to want to have a
baby it's one thing to want to have a
relationship and it's one thing to have
they will tell you anything
young dumb dudes will literally tell
take it from me my baby daddy's younger
they will tell you anything I have names
playing that I agree on that aspect I'm
not I'm not doubting you though I swear
like I don't agree with talking about
kids and talking about women but he is
making a point dudes that are 18 to 24
they will [__] you and your older you're
older and that's not taking away from
your value to you but in their eyes they
don't dude it's a [__] they don't value
[__] at that age except for the nut that
is coming out of their balls exactly I
completely agree with their standpoint
but your standpoint is from your
standpoint no it become a lot of
standpoints nobody has lived some 18 to
24 year old man in here next time please
and actually the first thing they want
to do no no what I was saying was men
she's right she's right 18 to 20 look at
my
my ex-boyfriend was younger than me I
really don't recommend but ladies ladies
ladies
ladies go older I'm telling just take it
from me
all right this is to my my 18 year olds
my 20 year old take it from me women day
older just just trust me on this
just trust me oh my gosh Neil Ray just
gifted a membership
you are too sweet
Andy's been a member for five months
amazing amazing look it
the thing ladies this is the thing
you see how bass that girl that girl had
a baby daddy that was younger than her
but the fact that she could accept
reality made her a little more
attractive
but
it's like when you're delusional you
lose a point oh of course we could do
paw you see this she she does Paw and
she wants to get my attention
I'll let that man breathe it's a girl
it's a girl
preferred women that were 18 to 24 years
old so what I'm saying is that men
universally prefer younger women
and it's one thing to look like you're
18 to 24 because everywhere I go people
think I'm the 18 to 24. okay so oh
they're lying that girl does not look 18
to 24. uh 27 to 32. I'd give her that uh
30 30.
okay it's not a fun fact people say I
look old all the time hurtful hurtful
but it's just life you know it's you
can't you can't really change your look
so it's just like just accept it
that's what I'm saying but the reality
is a girl that's really 24 is gonna beat
out a girl that's 34 even if she does
look like she's 30.
this is the point in fact that men
universally prefer younger women so your
statement from before go on your facts
we will go on your factory it's not my
facts oh my God we need to like go to a
mall
this is not my fact this is a general
fact of life that women men since the
beginning of time have preferred younger
women that's just how it is and women
prefer older men men because of things
that make a man attractive take time to
a choir women are born with their value
men must create their value
like this is how it goes like I know
that you're saying I make my own money
and I'm 34. you know what that the
equivalent is too let's say you walked
in a Starbucks okay you know she looks
four years younger you know it's like
you think you look 18.
18.
it's like why you breathe like that you
don't
with a black coffee I told him hey I
want a cappuccino I'm gonna trade you
this black coffee what would Starbucks
tell you
why would you do that the captain
Starbucks don't do trades oh they don't
right why
how annoying is this dog scale of one to
ten is a breathing too annoying she's so
cute though she's so cute no because
they already have coffee so in other
words you have to trade money to get the
coffee that you want not your own coffee
that's how men feel that have money we
don't care about your money if I do go
and it doesn't make you sexy I want a
cappuccino instead of coffee they will
give it to me but I'm just saying men
want women
you're missing the point of the whole
analogy the analogies
all right nice nice going Myron you know
this is point in some facts again
all right where what else should we
react to
Luis Davies
thank you for the Super Chat guys guys
let's just give a shout out okay so many
people watch for free
and you know I appreciate y'all watching
for free you know I I'm not hating on it
I'm a free Watcher too like a freeload
but a lot of people are saying my fans
are broke they're brokees they just have
no jobs they donate to you like only
fans blah blah
blah
so when you guys send super chats I can
let people know we don't got no brokies
here
and if you are please don't tell on
yourself in the chat
um okay let's see why is Carol
Delevingne did Cara Delevingne do
something
um she's definitely not annoying okay oh
good
I saw that Cara Delevingne is this
month's Vogue cover she's on the cover
of Vogue you guys might be familiar with
her she was a model and she is an
actress and she has struggled quite
publicly with her addiction issues and
she sort of hit rock bottom about four
months ago when she was filmed outside
of an airport terminal essentially
tweaking honestly she looked like a meth
addict and it was very clear that she
needed to check herself into rehab and
she did just that and by the way I want
to be very clear addiction is something
that afflicts every family that I know I
don't know a single person that can say
I've just never heard of anybody being
an addict in my entire life or nobody
and this is everyone's like Pearl what
do you know about [__]
I do know a bit about addiction okay I
had a crackhead in my family
not immediate family right I mean my
dad's one of 13 my mom's one of nine
kids you were just bound to have a
crackhead or an alcoholic or two and I
can think of three
and do I think any of them should be on
the cover of Vogue and sports whatever
you know no
no no no no
anyways
animal close to them has ever suffered
from addiction it is it is commonplace
in America especially because it's
essentially a narco state where we
celebrate people doing drugs all the
time we glamorize it especially
Hollywood but I was I was struck by this
interview with Vogue because it seems to
me that there's never any consequences
in Hollywood it's not her fault
obviously it's not Cara delevingne's
fault
um that she is inadequate oh my gosh yes
I was thinking about this with Demi it's
like okay it's a cycle we reward bad
behavior okay I'm gonna share my screen
in a second so I have a Google doc okay
this is what we do in Hollywood okay
what they'll do
okay
cycle
You Ready for This Ellie
okay I'm gonna show you I'm gonna show
you guys
all right the cycle is
cyclist first
it's
bad behavior okay now what is this
addiction
um
uh cheating right uh I gotta make this
font bigger don't I
foreign
bad behavior
addiction cheating
partying whatever okay
then what what do they get out of this
what's the next can I do a downwards
Arrow I don't want to do that okay
whatever what happens next we get
attention right so that is Media
piece on them so
then what happens next what happens next
they overcome it usually temporarily so
like you know
overcome it temporarily
this will typically include an apology
oh I'm so sorry so let's do the bad
behavior the bad behavior in this case
could be
uh Tiger Woods cheating now I know like
what what did you expect Tiger Woods but
let's just we're just gonna do that
Tiger Woods cheats then we get all this
attention and media on it
um then you know maybe I don't actually
know what happened but let's just say
they overcame it right temporarily
then we can do more attention and money
so what will happen is they'll make a
documentary about
overcoming or album you know for Beyonce
and Jay-Z or album about overcoming X
whatever the addiction is whatever so
then they get that then they fall back
again
and then the cycle just repeats so they
do the bad behavior they get the
attention then they overcome it and then
they get the attention and money and
they will just repeat this cycle
until honestly people are sick of
hearing it and usually there's no real
change so yeah you know I see what she's
saying so very difficult to live through
and she gives a meaningful interview
talking about her childhood now
obviously we know that she comes from
wealth and she talks about how hard it
is for her
um I'll quote her directly in this
interview she says in a way a lot of
people have looked at my childhood or my
family and thought she's spoiled there's
nepotism she grew up extremely
privileged which I did don't get me
wrong for the 30 year old but life
wasn't all that easy for other reasons
she talks about how she was first
introduced to alcohol at the age of
seven I woke up at my Granny's house in
my bedroom with a hangover and a
bridesmaid's dress I'd gone around
nailing glasses of champagne she then
talks about all of her mental health
issues in a burden self-harm and then as
a teenager how things progressively got
worse and obviously this is
I need to stop for a second for the
supers okay Angel of Sorrow you think
you're gonna manipulate us into chatting
nice try Pearl wait
I'm not manipulating you into doing [__]
chatter don't chat
all right what am I gonna do make you
chat it's like
sometimes guys you drive you drive me up
a wall
you drive me up a wall okay next thank
you to Auntie Jenny for showing and
teaching women the proper way a man sees
thing also how a proper feminine
respectful woman should be God bless you
can you get coach Overton on I don't
know who that is shows you how Mark was
privilege she has she's essentially been
struggling with addiction issues since
she was seven years old and yet despite
this she's been handed Awards in
Hollywood she's been handed uh you know
she's she's acting in huge movies and
despite us all watching her tweak
outside of an airport they still put her
on the cover of Vogue right so somebody
sent me this and said this is great like
this is somebody that's outwardly
speaking about addiction that can help
this morning that's great but she's been
sober for four months why are there no
consequences why is she allowed to be on
the cover of Vogue why is it that
because she's a woman
a woman yeah you had simply made a
statement if she had been sober her
entire life and had lived an exemplary
lifehood an exemplary childhood pardon
and if she was a stunning example to
changes everywhere they don't have to do
drugs but if she simply said I'm a
conservative she would have lost
everything it's very weird to me that
Hollywood
it almost celebrates depravity you know
what I mean like they they think that
there's something so wonderful and
artistic about the fact that she's
speaking out about her issues
um and the things that they're willing
to put a platform on like Vogue
definitely had her book while she was
because I worked at Vogue I know that
they pre-book all of their cover stories
so they definitely had her book and
didn't take away that it's just about
money it's because it's like
it's everything's about money it's just
yeah and control and power but mostly
money I think
hello dog
he was in rehab or because she was
suffering from drugs oh someone Louise
says how do I become a member
how do I become a member well
I think there's something wrong with my
page but you have to go to my actual
page to become a member
um even better yet you know even more
important than the memberships right now
guys sign up for my email list sign up
for my email list and my text list I
want to text you guys when I'm in
different cities okay so when I'm in
Chicago I can be like guys we're going
to this coffee shop at this day and then
we can all do meet up and hang out okay
it'll be fun
um ronaldus Alexander thank you for the
Super Chat Chef um Champion chopino
peace I'm a friend of Anton King Rich's
the lead attorney in sir Hale you have
me ready to book a UK trip to cook a
meal for you your panel and talk some
real [__]
yeah you gotta I like food
okay don't don't let me stop you you
know fiction issues I'm not saying that
they should have I'm just questioning
why it is that in Hollywood there are
absolutely no consequences for deprivity
it's just it's just a story one of these
things I looked at and I said I'm glad
for her I'm glad she's getting clean
she's correct and talking about the fact
that she's at the beginning of her
journey that's how it works when you
have addiction
um but there are a lot of other people
that they could have put on the cover of
Vogue and yet they chose to put Cara
Delevingne again no shame towards her
for outwardly talking about her
addiction issues
where are all the white people
protesting
the streets how come there haven't been
hordes of white people running into
Target and taking flat screen TVs or
running up on the Gucci store and
stealing some bags I'm asking this
question because there was a young white
man his name is Chase Allen 25 years old
and he has just been shot and killed by
police officers he did all the right
things according to BLM you know he
resisted arrest he did not want to
identify who he was he did not comply
with police officers and then he was
subsequently shot and killed
so first and foremost let's take a video
Let's Take a Look pardon at the police
video cam footage
will you hand that to me so I can read
it
any crack in your window
you're not going to hand it to me
sure all except I'll accept trusting
ship if you'll just hand me the
documents oh my God I hate it when
people are dicks to police for no
goddamn reason no reason I can identify
who you are because you're required by
also I kind of want to react to some
hate videos so if you got any send them
to me
thank you so much Mr Chase Allen
so you have a fraudulent passport
wonderful that's what I'm hearing
a car for me no
oh my God
sir step out of the vehicle right now I
am not
step out of this vehicle right now
step out of the car right now step out
of the car we're gonna break the window
and pull you out slip out of the car
those were the last moments of Chase
Allen's life it's difficult to watch and
the police officers obviously wanted him
to comply but he did not comply and they
shot and they killed him and yet we are
told that this never happens right
according to the prevailing Narrative of
the day I didn't even hear about this
never happens police officers always
take a white person peacefully ignore
the statistics that tell you the
Opposites if you are a white person you
are actually more likely to be shot by
police officers than if you are a black
man in America that's the truth that is
the truth but ignore the truth because
BLM tells you it's the opposite that
they get special treatment they're
allowed to do whatever they want well
Chase Allen didn't get special treatment
Chase Allen is now dead and so my
question is where are white people
because if Chase Allen was a black
person of course people would have lined
up into the streets there would have
been protests there would have been
people making signs telling you that he
was a hero telling you that officers
used too much force telling you that the
police the police all around the world
especially in America are racist and
they only shot him because of the color
of their skin so why aren't white people
marching today
actually I think I can answer the
question um it's because black Americans
are the only racial group in America
that marched to defend their criminals
the only ones Chinese people don't do
that Japanese
people don't do that Indian people don't
do that Hispanic people don't do that it
is a uniquely black American phenomenal
all right you know who I miss watching I
wanna need I want to watch some Thomas
Sowell
huh
so let me let me look at the chat let me
look at the chat real quick
hey when are you gonna call
um collaborate with Brian Atlas on the
whatever podcast I think soon I think at
the end of April when I'm back in the
U.S
angel of Sorrow welcome to the jpt gang
welcome to the jpt Gang all right
look it I'm one of the first ones
um
I Really Wanna
[Music]
there is justification
late 20th century to continue those in
turn I wish I could interview him Thomas
Sowell
I wish the genetic or racist explanation
you write that by the middle of the 20th
century even even a leading proponent of
the influence of genetic factors such as
the famous Infamous I suppose to many
people Arthur Jensen of the University
of California Berkeley up the road here
rejected the idea of an IQ ceiling for
some groups would you explain what that
means
well as Jensen said why are you
surprised that there are black children
with IQs of 115 and above
that in the earlier time in the early
20th century it was thought that there
was a ceiling so low that you had to
make sure that certain people simply did
not reproduce that's the whole Eugenics
movement right which was very big and
they were Eugenics courses by the
hundreds in colleges and universities
across the country uh and so Jensen
rejects that kind of rendition of it
well once you've rejected that really it
the rest of it becomes a matter of
much smaller consequence all right so
the the racist argument
is rejected on scientific grounds yes
rather than by rhetoric all right all
right so this brings us of course to the
other
explanation for disparate outcomes once
again
at the heart of the prevailing social
vision of our times is the seemingly
Invincible fallacy that group outcomes
in human Endeavors would tend to be
equal
or at least comparable or random if
there were no biased interventions yes
and explain that for us
well empirically is the easiest way to
explain it almost nowhere anywhere in
the world or any period of History do
you find any society and which groups
that compete openly
end up with the same results
this was a really good concept for me to
understand when I started listening to
Seoul I was kind of just I was just a
confused gal
I was confused I was in this liberal
college but I still had my parents
ground work
um but
you know
I was hearing all these new ideas and I
was like and they're talking about how
the rich white people were the problems
and I was like oh [__]
oh no what did I do anyways so
when he talks about different groups
having different outcomes it made a lot
of sense to me because my family I mean
honestly we're just goaded we just have
the best outcomes ever
um
I mean
so you know sorry on the genetic side by
the way uh
this is a study of families where
someone oh okay where are we hey
welcome to the just pearly things
membership hello Sabrina welcome welcome
she's a homemaker we got a homemaker up
in here right and we got two super chats
they keep calling my fans broke or I'm
so tired of this your dog reminds me of
the Pocket Bully with that white head
she's a good dog I actually I like she's
a very good dog I don't give her as much
attention as I should sometimes hey
Pearl I'm glad I caught your live show
love your content keep doing it those
large majestic creatures will learn
hopefully they won't all right let me
hold up hold up
we're gonna go on on to the YouTube and
put in
um
yeah
okay I need a little better video than
this
closest whale encounters do these look
like do these look like people that
aren't set in their ways
oh come on does this does this look like
an animal that learns
that learns speaking of which guys if
you want to be notified when we have our
our whale merch drop
sign up for the email list in the
description all right we're gonna go
we're gonna go one of the kids becomes a
National Merit Scholarship client not
finalists
in five child families
the firstborn becomes the finalists more
times than the other four siblings
combined now that's not genetic
uh there are other there it's also not
discrimination it's just luck birth
order the luck of the draw well it's
more than that it tells us something you
know what I'm gonna call my brother just
real quick I want to see if he thinks
he's the smartest one in the family all
right hold on I want to see
oh
because I'm not the oldest
hey
hey I just have a quick question
um do you think do you think you're
smarter than me
just yes or no
no comment
so yeah
no okay because I there's this video
that was talking about how the oldest
one in the family was the smartest so I
was wondering out of the original six if
you thought you were the smartest like
statistically you're supposed to be the
smartest
I guess I failed Statistics who do you
think's the smartest me
yeah that's what I was thinking like
who's smarter you or Greg is it nature
or nurture you know
but I was just thinking you know I'm an
idiot I can't be smarter than you
[Laughter]
I'm just saying I would say you're this
like if you if I gave all of the
original six an IQ test I feel like
you'd place the highest
anyways I was just wondering if you why
God
well you definitely got better grades
than me
yeah
you're like you're like damn that didn't
take much
nothing no I think I was at like a 3.0
but I thought you you got like a 30 on
your act didn't you
yeah I definitely did not get a 30.
um
what did Greg get as an as Act
yeah I mean
yeah I mean okay I was just wondering
no no she
she got
she might have gotten
um she was an honor so you could get
like a b and it counts as an a
did you have that too or no
okay you still have 3.3
you got a 30 on your act
how did you have that low of grades
[Laughter]
fair enough you know
because the test is like IQ and I guess
grades is application right
oh
although schools favor women so in
general
like learning
I wasn't
practicality
in front of those people yeah
well I mean like um
I put it like a lot of the
they just always talk about how like the
school system tends to favor like the
way women learn as opposed to the way
men learn so like men don't do as well
in school but it doesn't necessarily
mean they're not as smart
building stuff and
sort of thing kind of curious like that
Target's better
say that again
I feel like men do women don't like hard
things I feel like math is hard
what do you have a wedding date yet
cool I'm excited congratulations
at first I didn't even know for the
while because I'm not in that group chat
well I have you know I'm on and off
Snapchat but okay I have to go I was I'm
on a stream but I just wanted to know if
you thought you were the smartest
because I was like I feel like I would
say Austin was the smartest out of the
original six but I was like Greg went to
Madison so he might have had a higher IQ
than Austin
oh really I thought it did
oh
oh okay well well it maybe I'll call
Greg and see what he thinks who's
smarter
anyways anyways gotta go bye love you
bye
what a guy what a guy sorry y'all
importance of Parental attention in the
development of a child
and that's also reinforced by the fact
that twins tend to average several
points lower IQ than people born singly
gosh that's so interesting twins have
lower IQs than people born singly oh now
you don't want to do the reactions
of course
obviously no neither twin ever gets the
full attention of the parents
and also backing that up is that where
one of the twin is either stillborn or
die shortly after birth the other twin
twin has a an average IQ much closer to
the norm
I see okay so this which oh that's so
interesting so it's more about
the resources we eliminate the
argument from racism which leaves us the
argument from discrimination and what
you're saying is no no no no look at
example after example after example
where we know in more or less controlled
experiments families with five kids
twins and so forth that there are
factors that have nothing to do with
Justice or Injustice but that are simply
happenstance is that that's the argument
yes also it's true it's also true in
four child families three child's family
two child's families it is true in
Britain and Norway and any other all a
number of other countries where they've
been huge tests done all right so
um again I'm going to take
discrimination and disparities to bring
it to American society it might seem
strange you right that during the 19th
century of mass immigration from Europe
to the United States it was not uncommon
to find Jewish and Italian neighborhoods
in New York represented by Irish
politicians a situation that did not
change until well into the 20th century
how could this have been because if you
look at the history of the three groups
it's clear that the Irish had a lot more
political uh experience in Europe before
before any of them ever set foot on
American soil I mean it's really when
you think of how many factors there are
at work it's incredible to think that
they're going to work out the same for
for almost any group defined anyway
the other thing it's so frustrating I I
can I can come up with umpteen different
examples of this
disparities in various situations
including situations where it is not
possible for it to be either
discriminated
says something went wrong no did they
pull my stream again
they better not have
oh no they didn't okay if it said
something went wrong on my phone or a
genetics on the other side cannot give
you one example
you can read reams of paper by Advocates
of social justice and not find one
example anywhere in the world there are
people who've done International Studies
of broadale I quote the inner the french
fries
in no society that was all all parts of
the uh population had the same outcomes
all right you note also by the way that
even within this I found striking even
within socio-economic bands or strata
that is people who or ethnic groups that
are actually doing pretty well
uh there are differences that can be
striking and to quote you again Jews
have been especially well represented in
retailing finance and garment production
but by no means equally well represented
in heavy Industries such as the camboard
I actually do enjoy him but I've watched
that video so many times
[Music]
um
what should I watch
Street confessions let's see this
uh my name is Benjamin what's your name
are you guys together can we have a
couple interview
so
that's what you're talking about man no
it's not gonna get you guys in trouble
I'm not switching phones here don't
worry
I just want to have a I just want to
have a conversation oh if you guys pass
the test I want I want to have a kind of
a conversation that you guys might not
have had so I'm gonna start with you
my [__] what do you prefer intercourse
or foreplay
it's of course intercourse why
it's more mature
[Laughter]
what do you think about answer
hey hey do you give a foreplay ah I know
no I'm just asking do you give a
foreplay oh you guys go straight
man that's crazy Sensational how long
shall it take for him to come
80 minutes 30 minutes what do you take
30 minutes uh on on a bad day
[Laughter]
[Music]
Hi how are you doing beautiful girl
what's your name what's your name
listen I want to know right which
country do you think in Africa as the
most attractive man tell me
want to answer this
but I'm going to keep that to myself
which country do you think in Africa has
the most attractive man
I wouldn't have said either of those
lavender actually
um
yeah this is gorgeous girl now at our
race she is so gorgeous so she she makes
me think this potential there really
yeah I'm talking about guys yeah so I'm
thinking that if she looks like that the
guys also probably look like that no
it's that's wrong South African girls
are gorgeous but the guys are nuts
gorgeous I mean look at him
[Applause]
my cameraman shout out to you hey what's
up what are you doing
I'm good what's your name
what do you think yeah I thought these
are going to be crazier
um welcome Josh Davis to we got the same
last name welcome to the memberships
ronaldus Alexander two dollars I'm gonna
put this on my to-do list for the week
why
why are memberships
popping up okay
um yeah my bad they won't learn thank
you Dee
black man swimming I'm glad you can swim
because I sure as hell can I appreciate
your content
okay let's let's go watch something else
because
I thought these are gonna be crazy
oh you know what I want to react to hold
up
um
Jimmy Fallon
interviewing kids on the street
oh my gosh they're gonna ask kids
Saturday president Trump celebrates his
first year in office it's been almost a
year since the inauguration even though
it seems like it's like dog years it
seems like so many more
president Trump's approval rating
according to the polls that were
released today is that 37 which isn't
great but that was a poll of adults I
wanted to see what kids thought of his
first year in office so we stopped some
children out on the stream we asked them
how is the president doing and their
answers went exactly like this
how do you think Trump has done in his
first year in office great
what do you think he's done that's so
great kids are based kids are based
to save the world oh
from Harmony
do you think Donald Trump has done a
good job in his first year as president
no
why not
um because he wants to just kidding kids
are not based I take it back
small fingers and orange face
what's the worst thing he's done
um
I think he needs to stop threatening uh
North Korea why because I don't want to
get nuked what's the first thing that's
crazy there was not a war anyway oh
she's gotta be based
um pictures pictures of what
a princess and princesses
do you think he's smart no oh teach
these people badly and that's why I
don't think he's smart what's one nice
thing you can say about Donald Trump
he has kind of cool hair I think
whose hair is cooler his or yours
mine Donald Trump has a lot of nicknames
for people like crooked Hillary Rocket
Man do you have a nickname for him
um poop face
Mr tiny hands uh cheetah
can you do an impression of him
it's gonna be great
we are gonna build a wall and it will be
huge I will build a wall a big one China
oh that's funny
Donald Trump speaks out
um
[Music]
What Is Love from kids
uh mysterious thing right Guillermo
right Jimmy thank you um Love is uh it's
difficult to put in a word so with the
most romantic day of the year are
approaching on Sunday we thought it
would be fun to go out on the street to
ask children to explain love and well
this is what they had to say
[Music]
love somebody
and it's when you love somebody and it's
really when you love somebody what do
you think it feels like to be in love
it feels like
Heaven what do people who are in love
with each other do
they'd be gross what does that mean they
kiss they'd be gross if you're not in
love and you want to be what should you
do to find someone
go to a woman
's you know
what about Tinder do you think that's a
good way to meet people Tinder
maybe if it's chicken we probably they
would probably like it chicken tender
yeah
yeah it's fun to have on a date yep
do any of your friends at school have
boyfriends
I don't know that answer my friend
pretended she did but it was just a
stuffed animal
it was funny
because after school he knows what
happens with him
I'd like to do it
all the time
play with my Legos like girls
do you have a girlfriend
yes who is she Isabella what do you what
do you like about her
um her hair all right guys she has
beautiful
I gotta get going
um
I'm getting sleepy I just kind of felt
like I just felt like saying hi to you
guys in all honesty I felt like saying
hello
I just missed ya you know I missed I
missed the show yesterday
[Music]
um
yeah so I missed you guys
I'm very much excited for the events
we're gonna start to do sign up for the
forms okay let me look at how many Forum
signups we have
all right guys the form in the link in
the description are in the in the chat
it is so you guys can come to our event
so make sure you sign up
hit ring that oh my gosh like the video
on your way out and I will talk to you